ce soir on m'a offert une scène dans un
théâtre 700 paires d'oreilles et on m'a
demandé d'inspiré je me suis dit
pourquoi pas ça serait l'occasion de
sortir de mon laboratoire de recherche
côtoyer les humains de nouveau et revoir
la lumière du jour
c'est ainsi que j'ai décidé de vous
raconter mon histoire afin de vous aider
à mieux comprendre l impact est la
science sur l'environnement l'histoire a
commencé il ya sept ans j'étais encore
au lycée sur le point de choisir une
branche scientifique
quand mon prof de maths est venu me dire
you fera change des filières laissions
font trop compliqué pour toi ça fait mal
mais comme je suis un peu têtu j'ai
décidé de faire exactement le contraire
et de laisser un impact sur le monde
s'en fout
ceci ne m'a pas empêché de me poser
quelques questions et de mémoire ce qui
m'avait le plus interférer c'était
pourquoi la science fait si peur que ça
deux hypothèses me sont venus à l'esprit
la première elle est assez évidente elle
émane du fait que nous les humains on a
tendance à choisir les phénomènes les
plus simples et leur attribuer les mots
des plus compliqués et ceci à contribuer
l'éloignement de pas mal d'entre nous du
monde scientifique
la deuxième hypothèse elle est un peu
moins évidente et nécessite une
réflexion un peu plus profonde dans le
sens que dans lequel la science à la
base elle a été fait pour observer
l'environnement
prévoir son comportement afin d'assurer
la survie de notre espèce
mais au fil des siècles on sait de plus
en plus éloignés de ce bulletin est on
est passé d'un but constructif
constructif un bulletin destructif en
hackant dîner science industrie on a
développé des sciences plus ou moins
polluantes
on s'est mis à consommer sur consommer
mais on a fait suffisamment de mal à
cette planète qui nous a si bien
accueilli jusqu'à là avant de commencer
ma formation d'ingénieur
quand on me parlait de matériaux de
science la seule chose à laquelle je
pouvais penser été saisis mais à fur et
à mesure que j'ai appris un peu plus sur
le monde des matériaux j'ai compris
qu'il faut pas très différent de nous
les humains dans le règne des mais
trouve par exemple on va trouver
différentes classes sociales en haut de
la pyramide on va trouver les métaux des
plus nobles
eux ils ont la vie facile en fait très
cher pour les avoir et à fur et à mesure
qu'on va descendre dans la pyramide le
potentiel va diminuer de plus en plus et
à la base on va trouver les métaux les
moins nobles comme le titane le
magnésium et cinq essais dans les métaux
peuvent également avoir un trait de
caractère on va trouver par exemple
les capricieux comme les semi
conducteurs qui vont accepter de laisser
passer le courant dans un sens mais pas
dans l'autre on va trouver les fragiles
comme les céramiques qui vont se briser
en mille morceaux dès le premier choc
on va également trouver les dévoués
comme les uns qu'on va utiliser dans des
anneaux sacrificielle pour protéger des
aciers contre la corrosion qui dit qu'en
porte qui dit traits de caractères
différents dit également comportement
social différent quand on va mettre en
contact de métaux par exemple il ya
différentes choses qui peuvent se passer
pour faire court je vais prendre deux
exemples extrêmes soit ils vont avoir un
comportement répulsif comme ce qui va se
passer quand on aura deux aimants ayant
elle-même paul soit ils vont avoir un
comportement attractif c'est à dire
qu'ils vont s'attirer au point de
diffuser l'un dans l'autre et c'est ce
qui va nous permettre de réaliser des
assemblages maman ce qui se passe à
l'échelle atomique
c'est ceci on va imaginer un matériau or
et un deuxième matériaux qu'on va
appeler le matériau b maintenant vous
voyez l'atome jaune au milieu
le beau gosse avec des lunettes eva il
veut se rendre compte qu'elle attend
voisine elle est pas si mal que ça et
ils vont décider de se mettre ensemble
quand les conditions le permettent par
conditions je veux dire une température
élevée la présence d'humidité le passage
d'un courant par exemple et ils vont
décider de s'installer dans les
quartiers de madame parce qu'elle est
plus longue peut-être que son quartier
plus chouette
sauf que quand monsieur va déménager il
va laisser un vide
imaginons maintenant que plusieurs
couples d'atteindre ses formes
elle vend plusieurs vies de se former et
levitra s'accumuler au point
d'apparaître à l'échelle macroscopique
concrètement le matériau va se
détériorer va se désintégrer
maintenant en tant que scientifique
on va jouer le rôle d'agent de
frontières c'est à dire qu'on va
chercher
réguler le passage des atteint soit
enfin se dire oui nous on veut avoir un
dépôt on veut réaliser un dépôt du coup
c'est pas grave si le matériau b se
détériore et du coup on va maximiser le
flux dans un sens soit on va jouer le
rôle des méchants on sait bien que les
atomes fois c'est bien mais on va quand
même les séparer parce que ça peut être
dangereux pour la structure soit on va
être raisonnable et on va équilibrer le
flux dans un sens comme dans l'autre
et c'est ce qu'on va utiliser pour
réaliser des assemblages entre autres en
électronique
maintenant dans mon cas là le matériau
assez le cuivre le matériau bc latin
montre blême c'est que les temps il est
assis voces à et du coup madame cuivre
et la fin envie de se mettre avec lui tu
pousses qu'en fait on va chercher à
tricher on va lui mettre des lunettes un
état pion aux allures à lutter du fer
fin et tout ça est concrètement il
s'agit de l'ajout du plan actuellement
ça marche bien on arrive à réaliser des
assemblages karl ça ça on arrive à
l'heure et matin cuivre par contre le
plan c'est un mets tout l'ours est un
métal lourd par c'est un métal lourd et
c'est ce qui va faire qu'une partie de
votre ordinateur une partie de votre
téléphone
là il y aura présence de plants c'est ce
qui va faire que cette partie là et va
être non recyclables et qui dit non
recyclables dit accumulation de déchets
et notamment des déchets électroniques
en parle de 3 millions de tonnes de
déchets électroniques en 2020 soit
l'équivalent de 287 tour eiffel et 57
titanic
maintenant on a bien compris c'est pas
bien de tricher on va faire avec ce
qu'on a
on va juste faire
de telle sorte à ce que la première
rencontre entre madame cuivre et
monsieur et en soit la plus inoubliable
possible c'est à dire qu'on va faire de
telle sorte à ce que l'atmosphère soit
chaleureuse on va faire monter la
température à 300 degrés on va faire un
petit wanda site et on va les plonger
dans les villes de temps en temps
jusqu'à ce que le passage des atteintes
soit équilibré dans un an dans un sens
comme dans un autre
ensuite les couples d'atomes ses formes
vont donner naissance à une première
génération d'atom qu'on appelait
celui-ci 65 une deuxième génération
d'atom d'une série 3 est saine et cela
ils sont robustes ils ont des propriétés
meilleurs que leurs parents et du coup
ils permettent d'assurer un assemblage
qui soit le plus robuste possible
maintenant si je vous ai raconté sous
tout cela c'est surtout pour attirer
votre attention par rapport aux efforts
qui sont fournis alléché scientifiques
afin de pallier aux erreurs du passé
je sais que pas mal d'entre vous diront
la majorité sinon ça serait pas humain
on est tous contrarié par le fait que
dans le monde on utilise des armes
nucléaires des armes chimiques
mais on oublie que chacun d'entre nous
détient une arme tout aussi destructrice
qui est notre façon de consommer
[Applaudissements]
manon ce que j'aimerais que vous fassiez
à la sortie de cette salle que la
prochaine fois où vous essayez de faire
une nouvelle acquisition
imaginez tout le processus imaginez
qu'il va falloir séparer chaque matériau
a pas imaginer des petits box dans
lesquels on va mettre ces matériaux
chaque petit box est destiné à une façon
de recycler données plus ou moins
complexes et garder en tête que quelque
part il ya une partie qui va pas être
recyclé parce que si on continue à ce
rythme là on aura tous les gadgets
enfants rêvent mais on aura plus de
planètes pour vivre
[Applaudissements]